تبدو وكانها اشعه ناتجه عن انفجار نووي
مشاهد رصدتها كاميرات بمدينه كهرمان مرعش
التركيه قبيل حدوث الزلزال بلحظات اضواء
زرقاء ساطعه تشبه البرق في المناطق
المنكوبه سبقت الكارثه الكبرى تلك
المشاهدات اثارت الجدل والانقسام حول
تفسيرها البعض رجح ان تكون مجرد عاصفه
رعديه اخرون قالوا انهم انفجارات في خطوط
الكهرباء
لكن المثير هو تفسير جديد انتشر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مفاده ان الزلزال كان
مفتعلا وان المتهمه سلاح سري تابع لحلف
شمال الاطلسي معروف باسم هارب
الاتهامات جاءت بعد خروج بعض المختصين
ليتحدثوا عن قدره هارب على التاثير
بتفاعلات الغلاف الايوني لكوكب الارض
امكانيه توليده موجات اصطناعيه قد تتسبب
باضطرابات قويه تؤثر على الحركه الزلزاليه
او تؤدي الى انواع مختلفه من الكوارث
الطبيعيه اصحاب هذا الادعاء دعموا موقفهم
بمقطع فيديو سابق
ظهر فيه رئيس وكاله الفضاء التركيه
متحدثا عن ان قضبان التيتانيوم ان اطلقت
من اقمار اصطناعيه باتجاه الارض يمكنها ان
تتسبب في احداث زلزال بقوه سبع او ثمان
درجات لكن الصحافه التركيه قالت ان
تصريحات المسؤول التركي اوسيئ فهمها وان
هارب لا علاقه له بما حدث في تركيا وسوريا
رئيس وكاله الفضاء التركيه علق على انتشار
هذا الفيديو بانه اسيء فهمه واوضح ان
الفيديو منذ فتره وقبل حدوث زلزال وانما
حدث بتركيا نتيجه اصطدام تكتوني لكن ما
يمكن ان تحدثه قضبان تيتانيوم اشبه بفعل
النيازك للزلازل وان الامر بتركيا مختلف
اغلب اراء العلماء فسرت ظهور هذه
الاشعاعات بكونها مجرد اضواء تسمى اضواء
الزلازل وهي تصاحب الزلازل العنيفه التي
تحدث شقوقا في القشره الارضيه وانما يتم
تداوله مجرد ادعاءات يروج لها انصار
نظريات المؤامره ما يشاء على مواقع
التواصل غير ممكن المعدات البحثيه في
برنامج هارب لا يمكنها ان تسبب كارثه
طبيعيه او ان تقوي من حدتها
بحسب خبراء متخصصين فانه من الصعب على
الاقل في الوقت الحالي وجود اي تقنيه
قادره على اطلاق موجات اللاسلكيه من الارض
تصل الى بقعه اخرى من كوكبنا لاحداث تاثير
على الحركه الزلزاليه
وخصوصا اذا كان بحجم زلزال المدمر الذي
شاهدناه في تركيا وسوريا